[Music]
there are four magma chambers located
under the pectin mountain
the remaining three chambers will then
explode consecutively how much time do
we have
before it explodes again breaking news
the pectu mountain has erupted
according to the latest analysis it
looks like there are three more giant
magma chambers under the pector
we're sending you out on the new mission
report to base immediately
it's our job to fly there dismantle a
few missiles and get back home safely
okay
consider him extremely dangerous and
whatever you do don't let your guard
down protect the suit
i ain't over there i sent a bunch of boy
scouts
maybe he's not evenly i had a little
surprise visitor in the cell
give me a gun what
went better than i expected it to
if we don't stop them it's over for the
north and for the south so untouch me
and let me out of here
do you really believe that we'll be able
to get there on time
but if we can hit it we could stop the
last eruption
[Music]
you